detrás de un éxito militar una denuncia
de vulneración del derecho internacional
humanitario el senador colombiano iván
cepeda denunció la muerte de cuatro
menores de edad en un bombardeo de las
fuerzas armadas contra la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional ha
quedado establecido que en el bombardeo
que practicaron las fuerzas militares en
el litoral sanjuán en el departamento
del chocó contra un grupo de ln de las
ocho personas que murieron en ese
bombardeo cuatro eran adolescentes sin
embargo así había anunciado la baja del
comandante fabián el 28 de septiembre
del presidente iván duque y la caída de
fabián también valía el trabajo
impecable que adelantan los serbios de
colombia todos los días oghly ángel
padilla romero conocido como fabián fue
herido en un bombardeo el 18 de
septiembre muriendo después en un
hospital de la ciudad de cali era el
líder del frente de guerra occidental de
esa guerrilla en el choco en el pacífico
colombiano
el senador cepeda además denunció el
auge en el reclutamiento de menores por
parte de grupos armados ilegales
eso está claramente prohibido tanto el
reclutamiento forzado de menores como
ese tipo de métodos indiscriminados por
el derecho internacional humanitario y
por eso he dirigido en el día de hoy una
comunicación a la onu poniendo el
presente ese macabro cuadro que se está
presentando en el país lamentable la ong
aldeas infantiles denunció que en 2020
12 mil 481 niños fueron reclutados
aunque tampoco es la primera polémica
sobre bombardeos de las fuerzas armadas
en los que mueren niños en marzo en el
suroeste del país habrían muerto dos
menores en un bombardeo contra
disidencias de las farc mientras que en
2019 la muerte de al menos ocho menores
en otro operativo provocó la dimisión
del entonces ministro de defensa
guillermo botero